david alors quel va être le programme
des débats et bien écoutez comme vous
l'avez dit un prêt de 70 articles vont
être examinés durant près de quinze
jours annoncé comme l'un des derniers à
grands textes du quinquennat macron
l'objectif de cette loi est de lutter
contre l'islamisme radical et le repli
communautaire tout en renforçant les
principes républicains
ça sera tout l'objet des débats qui
promettent d'être intenses puisque le
texte en question fait l'objet à 2650
amendement fortement décriée par
l'opposition pour son atteinte aux
libertés fondamentales et une certaine
stigmatisation des musulmans pour la
france
insoumise et du côté républicain au
point du doigt l'impasse sur la question
migratoire la radicalisation dans les
prisons ou bien encore dans les
entreprises privées et damien abad
la chef de file des républicains elle va
déposer demain un contre projet de loi
philippe gosselin a débuté des
républicains s'est d'ailleurs exprimé à
ce sujet et lui elle dénonce beaucoup de
manquements dans ce projet de loi
séparatisme il faut lutter contre les
séparatismes et en particulier le
séparatisme islamique on l'a on l'a dit
sauf que le texte ne le dit plus en tant
que telle mais en réalité il ya quelques
quelques questions sur le statut des
cultes et ça ne vise pas que le culte
musulman les associations cultuelles
culturel les associations loi 1901
peuvent se poser quelques quelques
questions on a aussi sur l'instruction
en famille l'étau s'est un peu desserré
mais c'est pas tout à fait ça et je
crois que l'instruction famille même si
elle peut paraître anecdotique à
certains est aussi une des composantes
de la liberté de l'enseignement on a la
majorité a réintroduit par voie
d'amendement un certain nombre
d'éléments sur
n en ligne est en réalité évidemment que
personne n'a envie d'avoir de bashing et
des réseaux qui s'affolent derrière
l'anonymat etc
mais je suis pas sûr que le dispositif
créé répondent tout à fait aux questions
marine le pen a déjà présenté un contre
projet de loi mentionnant notamment
l'interdiction du port du voile dans
tous les espaces publics
le principal point d'achoppement de
cette loi devrait se porter sur
l'article 21 qui restreint à
l'instruction en famille visée par 384
amendement un record sur l'ensemble du
texte
il définit la scolarité obligatoire tous
les enfants âgés de 3 à 16 ans il faudra
également renouvelé l'aller
l'autorisation pour chaque année à
scolaire l'instruction en famille pour
chaque année scolaire
alexis corbière porte parole de la
france insoumise et dénonce lui une
atteinte à la loi sur la laïcité datant
de 1905 écoutez là où il ya un
séparatisme par exemple si j'accepte de
reprendre ce monde c'est le séparatisme
scolaire qui est la base de tout le
fondement la république c'est l'école
publique et comment accepter un
phénomène aujourd'hui où l'école
publique est de plus en plus mal traités
où elle est en concurrence avec une
école privée dans lequel des catégories
les plus favorisées n'ont jamais été
aussi importantes et se creuse
progressivement ainsi un séparatisme ou
selon la classe sociale à laquelle vous
faites partie les enfants ne vont plus
dans les mêmes écoles ça il faut le
prendre à bras le corps moi je suis élue
de seine-saint-denis je le vois bien
comment dans certains collèges les
milieux les plus défavorisés se
concentrer comment il ya une evans et
vêtements scolaire ici par des
dérogations à la carte scolaire assez
scandaleuse ou d'un seul coup les gens
arrivent à avoir une facilité pour les
dans le collège du centre-ville dans le
collège
à paris et surtout après le
développement de l'école privée
donc là il ya une pédagogie art fair est
ce que nous avons à financer pendant ce
qui concurrence directement l'école
publique ce qui l'affaiblît cette
première séance qui a débuté à 16h a
donc commencé par une prise de parole
des membres du gouvernement eric dupond
moretti et jean michel blanquer ou bien
encore laetitia avia l'une des
rapporteur de cette loi les débats vont
se poursuivre jusqu'à ce soir à 21h une
deuxième séance publique s'ouvrira
merci beaucoup d'être calife en direct
de l'assemblée nationale